got [ __ ] problems let's just go to a
juice box how about a Cuban flag that's
too much ink give you money on yes
that's for you
Jewish not me I'm just a [ __ ] Cuban
dude I'm saying something mixed with
water something that could float right
Syria do you want cereal like floating
in milk we have an employee that crud
that eats the edibles the it's dead
treatable for breakfast well I got a bag
I got a my [ __ ] the compressor case
there's an earthquake I got one of these
too leaving India noise hey dog bones
before when I was [ __ ] up when I was a
kid we what's the matter I'm just
writing down the time what time yeah no
no no because I don't I want you to make
I understand that's that's a beautiful
idea man is a Starbucks putting wheeling
K Cups 10 milligrams and the K Cup is
that correct and I read that correct
yeah I bucks or is it a different
company what does that tell you that
tells you that a corporation is actually
challenging somebody to put cake I'm the
only gonna sell them in Denver is that
what you [ __ ] think
listen I've traveled all over the
country if you don't think people from
Washington Texas drive to Colorado the
way we did we were kids let's go to
China timing your fireworks Thank You
giggling they tell their friends listen
I'll get you achievement you for 25
bucks they're really 21 they mark them
up and they take rides on Saturday and
they drive up the [ __ ] Colorado and
they pick up boxes of edibles boxes oh
my god when I travel people give me
auntie Delores places and places that
they should know BND Delores what you
talked about with us because people buy
your stuff people have offered me the
brownie on the road one oh the black one
black on black we can't keep
no we know that they do because no I say
it's the most discreet way to travel
actually and that's that's part of why
we develop these products because we
feel like people should be able to
consume you know their medicine wherever
and whenever they want in edibles Oh
how's it taste I'm on a [ __ ] flight
those popcorn that popcorn on a flight
on a 6-hour flight to New York when you
whip it out it because they see the
edible taste you up to the two-hour mark
yeah edible you take takes two or three
are up in a three-hour mark this thin
air it starts wearing down that's not
the vapor pen I always bring the vapor
pen of the plane with me I hit that
[ __ ] right there like a soldier
I also have another edible for the
three-hour mm-hmm what's the three-hour
mark comes you blast another [ __ ]
edible you get a little [ __ ] Bailey's
cream on the rocks sit back and hit you
little beep n I hit the little [ __ ]
nicotine pen to keep me balanced on the
flight you know mate though that'll [ __ ]
around on the flight if I'm paying
[ __ ] seven of hours to fly to Boston
I'm scratching my nutsack when the [ __ ]
I want
700 700 the plane industry industry has
got [ __ ] kaput the cheapest plane I
get up to Boston was 580 in August 7
[ __ ] hundred these plane tickets a
golfer or you gotta finance one tier you
know how much [ __ ] Denver you know
how much it would they wanted to Denver
who I'm southwest from Burbank one
afforded $50 guys that's how much I was
gonna pay for this big in Vegas yeah
right now the fly to Vegas I tried
looking for my wife this morning it's
500 bucks for her it's five for her and
fine this still flights available for
Monday morning I couldn't believe it
oh it's expensive I know but it's um
people are taking trips now to Colorado
in places it's like people used to go on
whiskey tours or they're going now so of
course they're gonna bring it back they
offered me a business to go to cholera I
don't pick people up you drive into weed
stores and talk about the history and
[ __ ] come on
I'll get stuck at 90 blaring oh yeah but
yeah yeah [ __ ] you I got time to like
I'm a scenic director the DMZ that's
where [ __ ] what's-his-name got shot
listen get in the back seat we'll go for
the magical mystery too huh when I drop
you off I want you to look at me and go
dog I'd like to do leg squats today I
have to do leg squats I've been pushing
against this [ __ ] thing I'm praying
for my life I brought him back from San
Diego in an hour and 35 minutes that's
my boy how long we did we take leave
from San Diego at night it sounds like
an hour and 30 how fast that we do what
was the least mileage we did an hour
maybe 75 right before the thing but then
we went up to 85 we take a brownie and
we go for broke Jack yeah you're being
that high doing that wasn't the best for
you for me it was tremendous that was
just floating on the [ __ ] of my
auntie Lois there's three edible chains
I mess with him you're one of them I
think
yeah [ __ ] tremendous I think they're
yeah because you can't eat the same
thing every day because then your body
gets used to it yeah so you got to mix
them around so I'm the chocolate things
up my all-time [ __ ] favorite then you
have ten million that's hard to believe
but we owe Dino we owe Dean on them and
then I put it took a picture of him and
that's how he caught it remember I took
a picture of the bag because the
chocolate bonbons first came on the back
oh and you've misread the weirdness well
I don't know you said 300 milligrams I
thought it was like a thousand those
things in it I was shipping them over
tipping them over in ten at a time and
[ __ ] giving him like 18 of them the next
day he's like [ __ ] no wonder I was so I
there were ten [ __ ] milligrams
two you know [ __ ]
that's now you in Colorado yet no no no
not yet you're happy just in California
that's all you're gonna be in Washington
soon and then Nevada after that no one
does no matter go into full effect it's
in full effect people are building out
their facilities now everybody's people
got licenses yeah who does the
California license work in the body this
is gonna be pretty awesome easy
well because everybody's drinking but
they want to do something else and
people are gonna be able to smoke weed
and casinos or at least babe actually I
don't know if they're gonna allow that
but but suffice to say there's medical
cannabis labeled the law pastor it is it
just like that is it is it like
California well there's gonna be weed
stores and no it's what I'll be able to
control excited medical and then I think
record I used to be on 26 yeah you know
recreational and imagine like these
young kids that go to the palms and get
[ __ ] up just on we and how many blunts
they'll be at those places I'd like to
see the numbers like food sales now the
waitress came up to me well sir was I
less what was I lastly before Michigan
Michigan where was that last week I was
some when I was in Oakland I was in
Michigan the waitress told me Saturday
night she goes between last night and
tonight more [ __ ] our food sales is
just tremendous we've never sold as many
appetizers I was [ __ ] yeah what's better
than chicken wings don't shake it when
you're [ __ ] stoned we think Lisa I
will your plans for Vegas
momma's not come away you're not gonna
bring him no I mean I don't know I'm
working like I have that working doing
that with me
yeah yeah you smoke some dope you work
huh
no no I'm bringing the recording stuff
no no it's fine
you don't want to go to Vegas me in the
room with you all weekend
no it's any Mexican would tell time to
Dolores your menu for Vegas some what
the first wait do you hear this [ __ ] he
already has a plan he's trying to
[ __ ] me
Stromboli place if you watch diners and
drive-ins and a hot diners drive-ins and
dives high like I do unlike the first
season we had the Stromboli place in
Vegas that's [ __ ] amazing I'm gonna
go there we're gonna be there in July
you should write down the name for us
like the three kegs or four kings or
something like that then when you guys
go in July is a business trip what are
you guys gonna do that you just you
would tell me when you came in tonight
you work on a lot of health facilities
okay oh yeah we filmed that infomercial
a few days ago for this elderly
community it's gonna air in their
television sets in their rooms and you
know all over they're the ones that are
really responding I think they'll like
Ari's mom are we still destroy they're
the ones that are really going you know
what I never smoke pot people look like
they're smiling I'm just sitting here
next to my [ __ ] husband all he does
is complain let's blow some shotguns in
his face and take this [ __ ] to
the next level our Silvia is [ __ ]
worried about the corns on your foot or
the [ __ ] things on your eyeballs that
you can't see it's over come down to the
first floor uncle Joey's medical
marijuana stores tonic giving out young
young for all you old [ __ ] come on down
mention Woodstock
if you were there if you were close to
it I don't give a [ __ ] come on down
mention George Washington whatever and
get a free [ __ ] and doozie I'll be down
there for the next 10 minutes that's the
ad you play for old people that wait for
[ __ ] something listen the last two
years I've read articles that I never
thought I would read in my life in this
lifetime yeah
I thought that maybe a hundred years I
can't believe how fast it's been more
once they spiked it and it's moving I
might online here am I gonna sit here
and tell you I were in high times as a
kid I never really did like I said I was
always just in New York City drunk kid
you know but this was always my drug of
choice it was a gateway drug for me I
loved them happy [ __ ] gateways
everything you know how boring my life
you know how uptight I was when I was
[ __ ] eleven twelve I would not listen
to rock music when I was a kid because I
thought those people with dirty and
satanic tell you that Catholic school
just people I didn't like deep with long
hair they [ __ ] scared me yeah it was
[ __ ] crazy like a wife grew up in New
York the people if you had long hair
they called you dirty hair
thank God you dirty hand they especially
in Jersey dirty hair dirty hair cuz here
you cut your [ __ ] hair like so I
never really grew up in that the people
I grew up with people that were jocks
that got high and I was like okay but
then they started getting crazy and
crazy and crazy they weren't like
regular jocks at regular schools the
jocks I grew up with mud people we did
[ __ ] THC crystal we did everything
you know usual jocks like oh no I'm
worried about my diet [ __ ] you these
guys we eat the [ __ ] steroids and
doing blow I never do this no way I
wanted to but I didn't have the balls I
can't shoot myself with a needle but
this is what it's become and you know
every time I go to Jersey and I have a
conversation it's like the third
conversation because they think not you
you're from New York City so they're
more wide open but there's always the
one people they consider California out
there you think that you people out
there [ __ ] crazy you hippies you're
walking around like they're at the beach
all day [ __ ] one traffic [ __ ]
that's why we need to get [ __ ] jizz
ills out here because who could take
that four or five traffic without being
that's the [ __ ] Lincoln if somebody have
you sitting on the floor five and
somebody's selling joints that's the
next moneymaker
like they do in New York with the
[ __ ] doughnuts just walking down this
me just warm
no he just walks in between papers like
the [ __ ] papers in the morning right
on the 405 [ __ ] some black [ __ ]
[ __ ] would [ __ ] hate warrants
what he's got to lose a cube or at the
beach like how it looks
like they walk on the beach and they
sell the water in the food beats music
in Jones Beach yeah probably but you
know imagine California guys walking
around with baskets they say in Mexico
you go to Mexico you're getting Sun and
some Mexican comes up to you and ask you
if you want to buy a kilo ball
that's [ __ ] tremendous and put suntan
lotion and those do cuz that's me Dad
tell you somebody offered me bug
yesterday and what context like where
were you
the Comedy Store Oh what did you say
well you think that [ __ ] inside I said
give it to me the next time no did any
part of you go like maybe not even not
even for a second what am I gonna do it
blown up my heart would blow up it's
been eight years I don't know everything
that I built the [ __ ] is done just like
yeah this was I didn't I didn't go to
rehab this is all my words so that's how
God works when you give you a word and
you stop I made a promise and I stopped
over my cat super bad oh my cat because
this brother had died they got Emilia
outside when you get an emu because they
were outside cats and their brother DJ
died but I was doing blow so I thought
it's because I brought the blowing house
I superstitious I am and I said DJ died
the super beds next and I was like I
didn't like super bad too much I don't
want to die either you know I'm saying
it so I got on my hands and knees I said
God if you [ __ ] let him live I'll
never do blow again here we go going on
eight years in November that [ __ ] cat
he's the only one I hold this way and he
fixes things in the room so now he's not
allowed to sit on nice shirts I gotta
put this shirt on I gotta put up I got a
bunch of white t-shirts with holes if
you people see me with a shirt with a
hole is because I'm holy it's because
these are my sketch shirts so I come
home and I throw my her and him and [ __ ]
oh great always cling on to me like they
always do that [ __ ] with that you know
their claws but they [ __ ] super bad
his nails come out it's really serious
it's all [ __ ] hot gooey with me I
love him I love that [ __ ] guy I love
my animals I don't want to lose another
animal if I don't have to so mm-hmm
I'm gonna start giving preventive
medicine that was very hard for the
house yeah [ __ ] lost weight like
[ __ ] yeah you gotta put that on
brother okay oh my god he's gonna rape
super [ __ ] lost weight she went from
zero to [ __ ] she went from 16 pounds
like six yeah in like six weeks we were
like she was fitting we have railing for
the baby and she wouldn't jump over no
more she would just walk right through
the railing more like oh my god and then
the Dow was very slow and then I think
with Adele did great but we were just
prolonging the pain we were just putting
a bandaid on one hole another one was
open destroy mm-hmm so when I came home
that was a tough one for me and then
when she told me about the stuff you
know me I'm always open-minded I believe
in it now so I'm happy you guys have
this I saw that the box my [ __ ] dick
got hard
yeah oh [ __ ] because I just been talking
about this with the cash so it was like
it was like a premonition type deal with
it was that a deja vu whenever you've
been there before
that's a great testimonial thank you it
really is when you get something like
this in the mail so now I know I could
give it to my cats oh [ __ ] it they're
gonna be dog gone I'm gonna you know I'm
gonna grind it up give it could I'm with
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that gets him high I
got some good [ __ ] I get from amazon.com
catnip
they go [ __ ] crazy all the other
cabinet more that catnip at Amazon isn't
[ __ ] Fugazi it's not good oh you put
it next to your cat they kind of react
there's one company that they when we
hit him up for sponsorship because I
like their products so much I loved it I
saw the effect it had on the cats yeah
they said they were putting their
products I had a production but it's
still on Amazon I went like an [ __ ]
and bought 80 [ __ ] bags and put them
over the [ __ ] thing all I got to do
is open up that cabinet you got to see
them running that stench is so strong
but it doesn't smell to me it's like a
dorm whistle it smells to them they go
[ __ ] nuts
and I give them that I give them that
day and I'll turn the lights off and get
the red light you know we'd do it but
I'm like the [ __ ] circuit I'm like
Barnum and Bailey for the cats you're
basically like a weed assistant you take
a dog listen well this is not gonna get
your cats I love your cats if you love
your animals you have to be involved
with your animals at Subway
you just can't feed them or whatever you
know yep Oh at night listen there's no
reason to get high if you don't have
[ __ ] like I'm sorry I'm not rewarding
this right if I have an animal it's the
cat's tone not with the animal by myself
and I wouldn't dare a cat was built for
a stolen when God put a cap on this
planet he said this animals primarily
for stone is that to look beyond the
[ __ ] some people hate [ __ ] cats
they don't know about the Egyptians and
for [ __ ] love they had Fritton the
voodoo they not how it changes your life
and people who have cats [ __ ] live
for six or seven years longer they're
giving cats to in VIX now in prison you
see that all that [ __ ] on scene [ __ ]
NBC on Friday but that homeless dude has
like a cat on his back his back all he
walks around the neighborhood yeah but
you know it's just I believe the power
of the cat so I want to give my cat the
best experience like today I'm leaving
for two days so today I think the girl
is my brush bowl the girls mm-hmm but I
give me tense brushes that metal thing
I go the other way I take the little rag
i watch the room muffler Lulu had a
little piece of [ __ ] her ass I can't
have a walk around like that with stuff
so I pulled it out of there you gotta
take care you animals if not why have
the [ __ ] animals you gotta give me
the love when I bend over touch muumuus
she makes this noise alright that's my
girlfriend those cats are my wives those
cats love me more than most [ __ ] here
was that brave a life of me he would
give her [ __ ] life of me alley they
would give their life of me Oh hmm and
gray I adopted when I moved up here she
just came to the door and I had a tie
how to put around lockdown for a few we
she can't come right away
then she got attacked by a possible oh
go back downstairs when I had to take
her in she's like my [ __ ] gross she
sleeps in the bed with me and my wife my
wife kicks around right to because it's
it's a pain man
she won't stop til she gets under the
blanket that she stretch our nose gets
wet I love that she's like I know people
get a whole deal your father's the
starters let me tell you something do
not harass auntie Dolores in her web
page if you ain't got a license go [ __ ]
yourself don't be so stupid
don't be so stupid don't think you're
cute well Joey Diaz said you'd sent me
no no play that [ __ ] right here you dumb
[ __ ] so we'll start your [ __ ]
all right
I'm nipping it now they should have
stopped Hitler in Munich that's how I
gotta do it you gotta stop these
[ __ ] if not now don't hit you
up auntie like if you want to call in
mm-hmm okay yeah Joey said that you'd
send me a box a big well they can become
a member of our co-op very easily now
our website is more functional for
California yeah these guys are the call
from Florida oh well maybe one day our
products will be in Florida those
[ __ ] back with Hicks they voted
against their southern Florida nobody
smokes more pop than [ __ ] Floridians
especially in Miami those Jamaicans is
[ __ ] down it and nobody they legalize it
cuz it but they got some [ __ ] they
got some heavy-duty behind all the drugs
and all that they got some [ __ ]
right-wing mm-hmm all Jews voting and
the Jamaicans don't really have a good
turnout well unfortunately they needed
sixty percent of the in that state and
they got like 57 or 58 and so it didn't
pass but most other states needed 50 and
so it's too bad that it worked out like
that for Florida because they it's gonna
be a while before they're able to
whether we're doing the auntie Dolores
medical [ __ ] product festival of the
San Jose sound god Joey Diaz Lisa R what
sprocket Black Sabbath to make an
appearance ooh yeah marijuana festival
$100 [ __ ] all you could eat puke and
dice [ __ ] come up with a
yardstick I like it I like it
yeah please the host with the mostly how
you feelin
so anyway you can find us at auntie
Dolores calm I'm gonna spell it a un
Tiede olor
es and the dog treats CBD rich dog
treats for your playful pooch treatable
is calm trea t ib le s calm and find us
on twitter facebook Instagram all the
usual social media channels and yeah
come check us out
there you have a cop's office oh yeah
and you can become a patient through the
website you can also sign up your
dispensary through our website if you
want to place wholesale orders and the
doc treats you can get them directly
from us we can send them to you in
California and soon and other states so
those you can actually order online okay
where you live only only I'm California
but you don't need a medical
prescription card to order your pooch
the dog treats you do need a medical
card to order the THC treats which are
for humans and we're not suggesting that
you give your dog pretzels do not know
if your animals anti-do are granting the
lorises for humans not animals
Marjorie very knowledgeable about this
what's New York's where are we in New
York so New York has nothing no no they
have they they do but it's no flowers no
flowers so that's what the law is that's
what the law is and they're handing out
so few licenses and they're so expensive
and basically you know already sort of
captured you know by large you know
hedge fund corporate entities so it's
been it's the laws are a mess I think
that they were created to placate the
the voters and the people who wanted it
they're not gonna help the patients they
have a cap on the amount of dispensaries
it's so few I can't remember the drive
five five through all of its like New
York how are people gonna get product
like that's insane so no no no flowers
just flowers and like can you like it's
so nonsensical WI less still the program
where people get the tendon filled with
joints from the government is that still
arriving yeah yeah because I saw that I
mean I think the reality is New York has
such a black mark such a strong black
market
and and honestly there's branded
products on that black market that
because these laws are so poor there's
no incentive for those people to switch
to the legal market basically they're
like yeah [ __ ] you
thanks like they're just gonna stay on
the black market and it's it's
ridiculous
hmm and tragic honestly very tragic you
know I know a lot of people need it and
they have to go on the black market and
pay yourself [ __ ] watching New York
those bicycle delivery [ __ ] oh
my god and they charge you 20 bucks for
a joint a half well also I mean when
you're working on the black market like
people aren't lab testing people aren't
you know tracking how much a dose is
like you don't even know what you're
eating you know maybe the person tells
you but really you don't know there's so
there's no you know regulation at all
which I don't think helps any consumer
one of the best things about the legal
market is that we actually get to know
what the hell we're ingesting you know
in any form this is why I love you know
packaging because I think that's really
gonna help people now we have all the
dosing listed on there exactly how many
pieces you know equals what are
everything you know it's a manic maybe
you can break it down so [ __ ] pubic a
pubic hair that [ __ ] we hell
yeah oh man I do not put that in all you
[ __ ] out there please support
auntie Dolores what's the web page
auntie Dolores calm and treatable is
calm and when can we get a hold of
Margery just in case some [ __ ]
eligible bachelors out there you bought
your call because they want a rubber
feet rub some CBD oil on my fungi nail
don't [ __ ] help it go away what if it
just disappeared immediately Lois it'll
do it oh I would [ __ ] drink that [ __ ]
cuz my insides gotta have something bad
in there oh [ __ ] as usual on accom
what's it calling it
optimum optimization that's I'm trying
to tell you [ __ ] if you want to
be the best at what you do when I feel
good about yourself go to Hana
they got some great products let me k
what's going on lost a couple pounds
okay I took the shroom tag now I'm
getting too much [ __ ] oxygen in my
lungs I'm getting dizzy because I can't
stop [ __ ] breathe it's amazing it's
amazing how my mind works so let's talk
about quit you did today you know that
why cuz it was gay I was getting busy
from too much [ __ ] air like those
from tech they what kind of mushrooms
they put me no of course that quarter
set mushrooms when you they give you
some extra energy they expand your lungs
it was just too much for me which means
they're doing the [ __ ] job so don't
just sit there like a [ __ ] jackoff
hey take our great products they got
supplements they got weights they got
[ __ ] kettlebells they got Monster
kettlebells they put out a great [ __ ]
product and it works that chocolate
protein powder that's what I've been
living on hill our two weeks because all
the other protein powders I was living
on give me that [ __ ] like a vicodin they
climbed you up that had protein powder
that days out from on if that [ __ ]
doesn't clump up in your stomach you're
in the back of the next day happy
whistling and [ __ ] I'm not sitting there
babe so let me tell you one go to
Hahnenkamm right now cut this [ __ ] go to
the web page see what they got
supplements ropes I can't take care with
the other [ __ ] but the supplements I'll
get you 10% off who's better than me and
not a small 10% a big 10% weak when they
put it in the box
Church BAM and you get 10% off your
product right [ __ ] now alright number
two listen I'm gonna tell you something
when it comes to snacks and stone is we
take our [ __ ] seriously how much longer
you need potato chips how much longer
you any [ __ ] how much longer you gonna
[ __ ] eat stuff that has cancer and
all this stuff I got the answer and they
gonna cost you who God's dick
naturebox.com/tyler products on the mini
the black and white pretzels the
teriyaki turkey jerky and the mini
Belgium [ __ ] waffles and put a half
of your skirt
never mind the Coco [ __ ] almonds and
then the French toast granola they got
sriracha cashews sriracha cashews they
got [ __ ] that's so healthy and when
you're stoned what do you want to do you
want to keep eating the [ __ ] you look
look take a look at yourself in the
mirror you look worse than I am being a
22 you fat bump stop eating that [ __ ] go
to naturebox combine now nutritious
delicious snacks they're gonna give me a
free [ __ ] box what's that that's
right
well there's anything for free anymore
who got nobody nobody everybody wants to
by the way they're gonna give you a free
sample box two big bags three little
bags go right now
naturebox calm down put in Joey in the
box they're gonna give you a free one
I'm the [ __ ] arm right then the next
time you're stoned you gonna thank me
for Joey's a [ __ ] genius this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] tremendous go ahead go look at
what they got try the black on white
pretzels your [ __ ] heads gonna
explode you're gonna get sent to your
house for free free shipping and of
course you like a dollar buddy what are
you gonna complain you're like the fat
lady with the ham at the harm who's
pissed off because you got no [ __ ]
bread you're fat [ __ ] go to nation box
that time right now and get your free
box sent right to your house all right
listen you're sitting there right now
you got crusty under way as we're
talking about on the way before I got
some [ __ ] tremendous underwear out my
[Laughter]
nose gonna be this kind of party and
gets pulled out of your [ __ ] skin so
your nutsack is fresh all right they got
woman's designs they got men's designs
and it's don't stop there either
[ __ ] all right there you go full
boat they got some t-shirts you can put
on me a geek
they got long-sleeve short-sleeve
tremendous they got women and boys shirt
I know you're saying let them go on
Santa Monica jump up and down we got no
time to [ __ ] hang out with boy toys
here this is for [ __ ] men and women
all right Lee auntie Dolores and
Marjorie right let me on these calm
right now they got some [ __ ] that's
right women and [ __ ] men's on these
knock your socks off their tremendous go
there right now they're gonna give you
free shipping in Canada and the United
States [ __ ] you understand economy on
these calm right now look at what they
got impressed what in the Box Lee Joey
mu and you get what off twenty percent
twenty percent so I'm giving you free
[ __ ] that snacks twenty percent off on
undies and I'm gonna get your head
straight you don't have to go to some
psychiatric [ __ ]
what's going on over there number three
so go to me on these dot-com right now
I'm pressing what Joey Joey I get 20%
off your first daughter have free
[ __ ] shipping in Canada and the
United States you're sitting there going
Joey Tamura Day weekend what movies do
you recommend well you'd go see Mad Max
you go see the other one pitch perfect
you'll see a lot of [ __ ] but what I'm
doing to your home at nine o'clock
everything you know if you go to work
Monday you want to stay up you my
Explorer gonna high end dragon TV right
though don't you want to see Chinese
people flying through the air poking
themselves in the [ __ ] eyeballs
classic martial art films for you right
there and iron dragon TV what do they
got week they got the MN series early
early Jackie Chan early like a
[ __ ] you still playing the drums
in the heavy videos all the videos
should have thrown sidekicks with Jesus
go to iron dragon tv.com right now and
get - that's right - [ __ ] free movies
explore see what they got - got none of
videos they are Joe Rogan talking about
meteors or some [ __ ] they got a bunch of
stuff on there go now go on dragon
tv.com right now and knock yourself out
they got some tremendous plastic martial
arts films you know love it you and they
got some new stuff coming in which I'm
not on top but we're trying to shoot
this show put the whole [ __ ] deal
together but I don't know what's going
on so I gave you alikom the codeword is
Joey I gave up search church I gave you
Joe a naturebox at college is Joey for a
free [ __ ] sampler I want you to order
something right now you'll get it my
[ __ ] next Tuesday but it's coming
you got me undies underway you've seen a
[ __ ] leopard print like that or the
camouflage I don't even know they gotta
zoom in dragon tv.com alright people as
far as everything else I'm at the South
Pointe casino next week I'm in Oklahoma
City and the week after lamb and Denver
Comedy Works all right beside that I
want to thank auntie Dolores for coming
on tonight and a beautiful little friend
Marjorie the York City I want to thank
the Flying Jew and I want to thank you
have a happy and safe weekend especially
if you're driving there'll be a lot of
[ __ ] up people out there a lot of
perverts put on underwear ladies because
we passed on the side of those
banging before they put you in the
ambulance it's disgusting I love you
guys stay black have a great weekend
we gotta say the less than that's yeah
right now okay